let's take one maybe two more calls 617
830 for 750 is the number welcome to the
show who's on next hi this is Sean I'm
calling from Austin Texas love it's on
what what's on your mind today well I
have a question about the impact of the
upcoming presidential debates okay and I
i don't i'm not very politically uh i
don't have a lot of statistical
knowledge about how these things work
okay and it to the extent that it can be
measured and i'm only asking this
because i feel like liberals like myself
we aren't forced to watch Donald Trump
in action however I've watched some of
his debate and in my opinion he when
looking through the eyes of someone who
can be moved rather easily like someone
who's being sold a car or something else
yeah below a vase and it seems like well
you know I don't want it okay yes I'll
say I don't want to be insulting I
wanted her people together but ok well
let's let's call that he is very
charismatic yeah I don't I think you can
insult his intelligence and I think I
can insult the intelligence effectively
all day long but to deny his charisma is
is a serious thought so let me just get
to the question cuz I know you're busy
yep um compared to other presidential
debates how big of the swing do you
think we will see after these debates X
trunk if the middle people you know that
the people who aren't you know going to
one party or the other uh [ __ ] are
exposed to this charisma and forced to
watch it as it yeah here's my third my
thought on this eronel i'll give you my
sense of it Donald Trump's charisma as
you talk about and his way of sort of
insulting people in a way that makes him
look clever or smarter or whatever it
works far better than you've got a bunch
of people on the stage and it appeals to
a to a broader piece of the electorate
when you have 17 15 12 10 a
five people on the stage like he did
throughout the course of the Republican
primary he can try and actually more he
can use the same attempts he can make
the same attempts with Hillary Clinton
but she and we know who she's working
with here in terms of preparing for the
debate she is going to come prepared if
you recall that moment in the 2012
debates where Mitt Romney tried to pull
Barack Obama then President Barack Obama
some kind of logic game and President
Obama sat silently and said please
proceed governor when Mitt Romney was
sort of trying to play a la President
Obama and he looked terrible right
Donald Trump is glass you if Hillary
Clinton is well-prepared really fall
flat with those tactics and while I
agree with you that to the low
information voter the sort of
belligerent ad hominem charisma that
you've described may be appealing at
this point we're starting to work only
into the middle right these sort of
skeptical uh skeptical Democrats these
uh Republicans who are moderate but are
not really liking Trump's ideas and and
his belligerence and I don't think by
and large they are going to be swayed by
by what you're describing is Trump's
charisma so that's my sense of it really
really good question i appreciate the
call okay thank you very much and thank
you for your show and everything else
all right pleasure hope to speak to you
again